well thank you you did well for me well
honey your second consecutive year as
host how are you feeling right now I
feel good I got a lot of clothes to
change into got a lot of fun things that
we're doing tonight with God so I think
it's gonna be a fun show our Garden's
okay yeah okay doing good good yeah okay
I got to tell you Dolly your Rockstar
album cover art
OMG you look like a vixen well I tried
really hard look like a rock star oh my
God weren't you excited about premiering
your debut single from that album
tonight well I'm excited a little bit
nervous but in a good way well it's like
I'm introducing my whole Rock album
tonight yeah and this is the first
single from that but it's a good message
I think everybody in the world needs to
kind of hear this so I'm excited about
it I love it it's just fire fire the
world's on fire you sing it girl no I'm
Gonna Leave it to you Dolly but it is in
my head honey good I love it have fun
tonight
[Music]
thank you